can we assume that it was in your uh in
your camp that that uh
the jacobi learned how to how to throw
passes in the in the rain on
a double pass i'm not going to confirm
nor deny that
i think jacoby has always been able to
throw it you know and um you know i was
teasing with him before that before the
play was called
i said bro don't panic now he said i
mean i got to take out my gloves i got
to take out my club
but i'm gonna do it so they won't so
they won't recognize nothing
so he took off one glove and he takes
off another one
bro what are you doing i gotta take off
another one bro oh no
he did pretty good without being able to
you know say warm up or anything
and uh the hot was covered on that plate
which was me
those will show you the respect you know
in the passing game but
uh he did a great job and you know
berkey
you know only thing he knows how to do
it just score a touchdown seems like man
he just made a big play for the team it
takes
a certain amount of poise for somebody
who's not a quarterback to
to make that throw in those conditions
in that moment once a quarterback always
a quarterback
you know i'm pretty sure julian edelman
is somewhere smiling
and uh but nervous at the same time if
you know what i mean
i'm not gonna necessarily say it's a
turning point we just we just want to
keep getting better each and every week
and i think we've been showing that
finding different ways to win
[Music]
you take it off you know don't nobody
like losing i know none of you guys are
like losing you know um
especially we know we got a lot of
talent on our team um we got to recruit
you know tuesday we go watch someone our
opponents from tennessee
and we're gonna build from there
you know every team that had a great
season that follows it up with a not as
great season has that moment where
they end up with more losses than they
had the prior year and that's what
happened to the ravens last night 14-2
is not happening again for baltimore the
best they can do now is 13-3 by virtue
of the third loss that they took last
night
against a team they dominated last year
chris when the patriots were eight and
oh this time around
the patriots never let baltimore get
moving always found a way to answer
always found a way to do something
pulled out the bag of tricks with the
jacoby myers throw to rex burkhead and
uh just constantly cause the weather
didn't help but hey the weather is what
it is baby
uh you you get you get rain you get wind
you get all sorts of stuff when you play
football in november and december
but baltimore was leery
and and and uh they had they had good
reason to be leery of the new england
oh definitely well you know bill
belichick i mean first off and then cam
newton what he's doing and just the
offense i mean first off bill belichick
got a chance to see that offense last
year yeah they defended it better this
year they didn't let lamar jackson and
company run wild on them certainly
we saw baltimore be very sloppy and do
things that we normally don't see them
do
so that was a big issue and then i think
ultimately i mean the new england run
game
it it it did to baltimore what most
people
you know see the effects of baltimore's
offense
i mean they smash mouth baltimore and i
didn't think they were i knew they were
a good running team i didn't think they
were capable of that and that was really
impressive
yeah and it was just that sense that
this you know it happens how many sunday
nights is it going to happen
where the better team the better team
yeah
ends up losing i guess that makes for an
exciting slate of games it makes it
impossible to figure out with any degree
of
of certainty who's going to win
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports